[Music]
straight ahead on Law and crime daily we
take a deep dive into the arrest of
Brian coburger the man accused of
ruthlessly stabbing four college
students to death family members of
those young victims are ready for his
extradition back to Idaho I want him to
be sick of seeing us and sick of knowing
that these people won't let it go we're
breaking down the science behind the
investigation as well as the impact the
alleged Killer's interest in criminology
may have had on the crime scene we've
taken leaks Leaps and Bounds we've
jumped ahead in the recovery of evidence
and what's next for the suspect I'm just
as anxious and the family is just
anxious to see the probable cause
affidavit as everyone else's lawn crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Long Prime daily
I'm Jesse Weber we're bringing you the
very latest on the arrest of Brian
coburger the 28 year old grad student
accused of mercilessly killing four
University of Idaho students the
Washington State University doctoral
student made his first court appearance
on Tuesday walking into the courthouse
hours before his afternoon extradition
hearing coburger was arrested in
Pennsylvania thousands of miles away
from the Idaho 4 investigation when a
semester at Washington State ended in
December he and his father took a
pre-planned cross-country road trip back
to Pennsylvania now that trip was done
in a white Hyundai Hyundai Elantra which
we told you Moscow police were looking
for for weeks they were actually pulled
over twice in Indiana once for speeding
and once for tailgating the Moscow
police chief says that the Department's
only interaction with coburger in the
small town was a traffic citation for
driving without a seat belt he now faces
charges that include four counts of
first degree murder as well as burglary
the Pennsylvania State Police just gave
a press conference with details about
coburger's apprehension
those affidavits attached to those
search warrants are still under seal so
I can't discuss their contents with you
but one was for the person of Mr
coburger
collecting DNA and photographs that sort
of thing one was for the white Elantra
vehicle
which I understand has been seized and
is being processed and one was for the
address the residence itself that he was
living in
with his family
um I was at the scene and I have to say
that major Paris and Captain Norm Kramer
did an outstanding job in coordinating
the efforts not only of the numerous
Pennsylvania State Police Troopers there
but officers from other jurisdictions
and disciplines within those
jurisdictions to make this a very smooth
highly competent professional operation
um it is a quirk apparently it's not in
the norm of the states I'm familiar with
that Idaho does not release
there are probable cause affidavit in
support of their arrest warrant until
after their defendant is brought a
return to that state
but having uh read those documents and
the sealed affidavit's a probable cause
I definitely believe that one of the
main reasons the defendant chose to
waive extradition and hurry his return
back to Idaho was the need to know what
was in those documents so that's a
significant development
beyond that
looking at the the scope of the uh the
situation and the ties this defendant
has to my County
um I would hold our office at the
disposal of the Idaho authorities
to help facilitate a complete background
investigation into the defendant
both activities prior to the murders
occurring within the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania and his activities after
the murders in Pennsylvania so we stand
ready to assist with that effort on an
ongoing basis
some interesting comments there while
Steve Gonzalez who's the father of
Kaylee has been very vocal since the
start of this investigation and he told
media Outlets that he and the other
parents plan to be there when co-burger
appears in an Idaho Court in an
interview with NBC News he said the
families still want answers
next mission is really Divine Justice
and and make sure that
uh we have a closing chapter that meets
the expectations of all the families
call Berger's family released a
statement through a public defender it
says in part quote we care deeply for
the four families who have lost their
precious children there are no words
that can adequately Express the sadness
we feel and we pray each day for them we
will continue to let the legal process
unfold and as a family we will love and
support our son and brother long crime
correspondent Sierra Gillespie was in
Monroe County Pennsylvania for
co-berger's extradition hearing she
joins us now Sierra it's good to see you
this was a very quick hearing but an
important one
yeah Jesse this hearing was less than 30
minutes in all but when Brian
Christopher coburger entered the
courtroom it was completely silent you
could have heard a pin drop he came in
wearing a red jumpsuit and handcuffs and
avoided The Gaze of the dozens of
reporters that filled the courtroom and
instead looked to the front row where
four of his family members were seated
coburger's family they were drawing a
lot of attention to them because they
had their hands on each other kind of
hugging each other and one family member
actually was so distraught and crying
that a sheriff's deputy brought over a
box of Kleenex to give to her to kind of
calm herself down but as far as
co-burger he told the presiding judge
here in Monroe County that he's waiting
extradition he's saying he's doing this
without coercion at his own volition
saying he believes that this is the
right choice to head back to Idaho
something to note here is that coburger
stood for majority of this hearing he
seemed confident he didn't quiver at all
his voice was very strong and he
responded to to the judges if he totally
understood what she was saying from here
though we're expecting coburger to be
taken back to Idaho within the next 10
days and after his first initial
appearance in Lata County that's
hopefully when a now sealed probable
cause affidavit will be unsealed and
will learn more information about what
led up to coburger's arrest and the
murder investigation as a whole
reporting live in Stroudsburg
Pennsylvania Sierra Gillespie long crime
Network Sierra thank you great reporting
as always correspondent Anjanette Levy
hosted a q a session during the
lunchtime hour today getting expert
Insight from experts to answer your
questions about the Idaho murder
investigation and Joseph Scott Morgan a
forensic death investigator says that
the suspect's interest in criminology
likely doesn't help him as much as my
people might think
we've taken leaps Leaps and Bounds we've
jumped ahead in the recovery of evidence
I had a long crime daily we check in
with the DNA expert to sit through the
places that the suspect could have left
to trace in the home where those four
college students were brutally murdered
but first why did law enforcement arrest
Brian kohlberger while we explore the
requirements needed for probable cause
as officials wait for the suspect's
extradition back to Idaho
[Music]
welcome back everybody probable cause is
a phrase we hear a lot when we cover
investigations arrests and trials it's
part of our Fourth Amendment right when
it comes to searches and seizures now we
know that police have executed search
warrants at Brian coburger's apartment
and office at the Washington State
campus and so far there's been no update
on the identification or location of a
murder weapon for now the probable cause
affidavit would justifies coburger's
arrest will stay sealed but once he's
back in Idaho to face trial the
documents could be unsealed so I want to
bring in my co-host and public defender
Brian buckmeyer you've dealt a lot with
this and it can get a little difficult
because so much of it is really up to
interpretation right Jesse up to
interpretation is putting it Molly you
could probably put 10 defense attorneys
in a room and get 10 different
definitions of probable cause but no
warrants shall issue but upon probable
cause that's what the Fourth Amendment
says about probable cause and course of
try to Define it but it is no actual
universally accepted definition instead
courts give this flexible totality of
the circumstances approach in defining
what a reasonable and prudent person
would believe a crime did is or will
happen that means what we may find in
this case could be very Broad in showing
why coburger is believed to have Commit
these four murders and this burglary
charge but based on what you know so far
I'd expect the arrest warrant and the
affidavit attached to be heavily reliant
on the tracking of this white Elantra
the surveillance of Coburg across the
country we would probably learn a lot
about the cause of death from the
victims and the DNA collected at the
scene DNA found at this scene could be
skin cells but I would bet that it's
more likely than not blood probably of
the victims or probably on the victim
sorry or close to where they were
murdered because don't forget this is a
party house it will be hard for the
investigators to differentiate other DNA
from that of the suspect so I think it's
going to be close by to the victims well
let's bring in former trial attorney my
co-host Terry Austin as well into the
discussion so Terry it seems like all
the evidence so far is circumstantial
there's a lot we don't know is it too
early to say that it's enough to secure
a conviction well you know it sounds
like there is quite a bit of that
circumstantial evidence Brian was just
talking about some of that first of all
we have that car we have DNA those are
two big pieces of evidence that the jury
is going to take very seriously and now
we know they have traced him across the
country where did he stop what did he
buy what is that surveillance camera
going to tell us across the country so I
think they have a lot of evidence and I
think the jury is going to think about
it even if there is no eyewitness you
know remember they're going to get a
charge that says circumstantial evidence
is just as good as direct evidence and
so if there's enough of that which I
think there will be add on to all of
that you know his credit card receipts
his phone data there's plenty of
evidence here we've seen convictions on
circumstantial evidence and I think
we'll see something here and the
community wants it yeah of course and
there's a lot that can happen between an
affidavit and ultimately a trial and I
know that the police have asked for more
information about coburger coming up on
Long crime daily co-burger has only two
choices for a public defender in Idaho
we speak with the attorney for a
victim's family about what's next X for
the suspect Plus
that's why they were able to capture
this guy
DNA helped police put a face to the
crime scene back in November we turned
to an expert to discuss where it might
have been collected and why it took so
long to release the information
[Music]
and welcome back everybody Moscow Idaho
officials announced the arrest of
suspect Brian coburger on Friday but
behind the scenes they identified him as
a suspect more than a month ago through
the use of DNA evidence law enforcement
said genetic material found that the
crime scene matched coburg's identity
genetic genealogy techniques were used
to run the material through a public
database to try to find potential family
member matches the recovered DNA
combined with other evidence traced the
genetic material back to co-burger the
victims families are working with law
enforcement to find out how they may
have known the suspect if at all but
with no weapon in custody what genetic
material was actually recovered and from
where well we spoke with DNA expert Dr
Monty Miller to explore the
possibilities
they must have found some blood a glove
a shirt a hat I mean something you know
where they were confident that it was
his DNA or maybe they found three or
four things of interest and they ran
them all through the database and they
picked his out because they found
somebody who lived close I don't know
Network you know when it is something of
that magnitude a lot of people get
involved and the DNA gets run real
quickly and and you know all ideas are
explored almost simultaneously which
makes it nice and that's why they were
able to capture this guy my my guess is
they already had a profile that they
were looking for and as soon as they got
him they stuck him into one of those
machines and said yeah this is our guy
you know because they don't want to
create a media storm when you know they
don't want to you know they want to know
in advance so my guess is they've
already done that
um but I don't know that to be true
Terry it sure seems that authorities are
using DNA to capture and convict
suspects suspects a lot more now but
does a DNA match guarantee a conviction
no it doesn't guarantee anything I think
we will continue to see an increased use
of DNA testing but that's to use the
suspects to find them but I don't think
we're going to get all these convictions
authorities have been using DNA remember
since the late 1980s the first use of
DNA in court was actually against a guy
named Tommy Andrews he was accused of
raping a woman at night point during a
burglary that was in Florida his DNA was
collected from the crime scene and he
was sentenced to 22 years in prison now
of course everybody remembers the O.J
Simpson case although there was clear
DNA matches in the O.J Simpson case the
defense argued that the DNA was
mishandled that it was contaminated
during collection and processing and it
actually raised enough doubt that the
jury ultimately found him not guilty so
DNA testing actually began only with
blood samples today as we heard from our
expert DNA testing methods has
significantly improved and DNA can be
gathered from blood skin anything hair
bone saliva semen so you know it's
interesting Jesse one thing you have to
think about is you can use DNA to
convict but you can also use DNA to
prove that somebody's innocent that's a
good point Brian you mentioned earlier
that the DNA would likely be blood and
not skin cells why do you say that what
does that tell us yeah it's the location
that we're talking about I've defended a
lot of cases where they're in party
houses or what you call a trap house
where like drugs and guns are being used
and we have so many people coming in and
out of a location it's hard for an
investigation to pinpoint who they're
looking for but if you have blood
especially in a brutal murder like this
where there's a high likely chance that
the weapon might have slipped Nick the
the suspect his blood would have ended
up there now you're not looking at a
bottle with four or five people touching
it and saying all right who's the person
we're looking for now you're looking for
blood in an area that's not the victims
and and that's a lot easier to pinpoint
and say all right this is the person we
need to go after and like Dr Miller said
they probably already had a profile he's
just someone they had to spot on and get
once they got something else to compare
to that DNA and also you have to imagine
that if you didn't have a ready
connection that his DNA being in a place
where he'd never been before raises
different difficulties for the defense
as well and we told you earlier in the
show that correspondent and Jeanette
Levy hosted a q a question and answer
session during the lunchtime hour and
she got Insight from experts to answer
your questions about the Idaho murders
investigation so let's hear from Joseph
Scott Morgan forensic death investigator
because he told us while the alleged
suspect was interested in criminology
that doesn't mean he's going to get away
with anything
there there are people that are out
there that are conflating the study of
criminology with the study of forensic
science
and nothing could be further from the
truth yeah we cross paths with
behaviorists all the time however that
that doesn't make you an expert in crime
scene investigation as a matter of fact
he probably knows very little at all
about the process of working a scene and
certainly processing the evidence and
what we're specifically looking for when
you get down into the details and this
case is all about details and we're
going to look in places that he probably
thought about but some places he didn't
think about and all right when we come
back there are four public defenders in
latex County Idaho and two of them have
recused themselves so who's left for
co-burger an attorney for one of the
victims families has some answers
foreign
[Music]
new information Tuesday about legal
representation in Idaho the man accused
of stabbing four college students to
death says he needs a public defender
but there are only four in the county
the state of Idaho doesn't have a public
defender system instead four attorneys
have contracted to help out one of those
is actually the coroner while she didn't
perform the autopsies on the victims she
does have inside knowledge about the
reports and other information so she's
recused herself as did another attorney
in that office who works with the police
we learned during a Tuesday afternoon
news conference that the chief public
defender for another Idaho County was
selected to represent co-burger long
crime spoke with Shannon gray the
attorney for the victim of the attorney
for the family of victim Kaylee Gonzalez
and he broke down what's next for
co-burger
everyone thinks that I think that he's
going to give back here and he's going
to automatically be arraigned on the
case and that's just not the that's just
not what's going to happen he's going to
his first appearance will probably be
getting an attorney so uh get either a
court appointed attorney or someone you
know is if they've the family hires an
attorney I probably retained attorney
and then that attorney is want to going
to want a couple days to talk with his
client
um and then they'll have the preliminary
hearing
um
regarding the probable cause for the
arrest and then obviously the Layton
County we'll have to get a grand jury
that's for the indictment and uh he can
be arraigned on an information prior to
the indictment and be held on that and
then so I mean that there's a lot of
moving process things that are going on
that that aren't going to happen
immediately
Brian you're a public defender and not
having court appointed councils a
problem anywhere you look but I think
it's really compounded when there's such
a small town experiences such a heinous
and public crime right absolutely Jesse
Justice no matter how you look at it
will be delayed ever in the United
States has a right to counsel and if you
can't afford one a public defender will
be given to you when how and how well
funded though really depends on where
you're arrested back in 2015 Lata County
Idaho considered getting a fourth public
defender after the state was sued by the
Idaho ACLU and demands remain to make a
centralized offenders office but it
doesn't seem like much has changed
that's probably why he's being
represented by Ann Taylor or reportedly
so by Ann Taylor the chief public
defender of Kootenai County that's just
30 miles east of Spokane Washington on
the border of Washington Idaho and about
a hundred miles north of Moscow Idaho
this Patchwork of having a public
defender from another County stepping in
to represent co-burger will likely help
to expedite the case in some way but
having a pub Defender who lives and
works a hundred miles away will create
its own hurdles in the case both for
representation and Expediting case but
with the Public's eye on the case that
may help the process be more efficient
but that's still still going to be a
long road to Hope Brian makes some great
points Terry but here's the problem what
happens if something happens to her what
happens if she can't represent him
anymore what if none of the other public
defenders can take the case what happens
then well you know it's a really good
question what the courts are going to do
is continue to look for other public
defenders but if they can't find a
public defender in any County in any
surrounding County what they're going to
do is go to their list of private
practitioners and that could be someone
who's solo that could be someone out of
a law firm and remember these people in
law firms are looking for pro bono work
some of the states require that you have
a certain number of hours of pro bono
work so we have that one thing I will
say if in fact they have to go to these
private attorneys whether it's solo
whether it's a large firm I think these
people are going to hesitate a little
bit because they may be criticized for
taking the case because it's such a big
public case they could also be
criticized because it's such a heinous
crime so if you have to go public or
private it's probably better to go with
a public defender who is accustomed to
taking the abuse when you have a case
like this well let me
Brian's laughing that Brian I'm going to
throw this to you real quick 30 seconds
what's the first conversation that the
attorney has with Brian coburger did you
do it I mean what's the conversation
like so a lot of public defenders vary
on that as to whether or not they want
to know if their client to committed the
crime the first thing you want to do is
create a relationship with your client
they are the best source of information
uh really you're just going over the
affidavit giving them information and
telling them how you're going to
represent them and then tell them you're
going to take a lot of abuse because
they're a public defender as Terry said
yeah well and not only a public defender
a public defender in such a high profile
case where there are so many people who
don't want to hear about coburger's
defenses or co-burger's rights which we
have to remind everybody here on a legal
show everybody is entitled to the same
rights and he is innocent until proven
guilty we're at the beginning stages of
this investigation in this case and
we'll see where it goes Brian Terry
great job as always thanks so much
everyone thanks so much for joining us
here on Long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America
[Music]